فيما يتعلق بحزب البعث العربي الاشتراكي
الاردني بدا منذ عام 2003 جدل يعود اليوم
الى الواجهه بعد تصويب اوضاعه وفق قانون
الاحزاب الاردني الجديد الذي سمح لسته
وعشرين حزبا بالعمل على الساحه الاردنيه
هناك سوء فهم واضح فيما يتعلق في المرحله
الجديده للحياه الحزبيه في الاردن حزب
البعث العربي الاشتراكي الاردني هو وفق
اوضاعه بموجب احكام القانون ولم يرخص من
جديد المطلوب من هذا الحزب فقط العمل داخل
حدود المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه بموجب
احكام الدستور والقانون النافذ حزب البعث
رد على الانتقادات التي تشنها جهات في
العراق على الاردن بعد السماح له بالعمل
رغم انه محظور هناك بحسب الدستور ووصفها
بالحمله غير المبرره حزب البعث العربي
الاشتراكي حزب وطني اردني مؤسس منذ 92
ولازال قائم وفق وفق اوضاع وفقد وبالتالي
ماء الزوبعه
الان ليست مبرره على الاطلاق وكلام مش
صحيح الاطلاق مش صحيح احنا موجودين وهي
مساله استمرار فقط انا لبيت شروط القانون
هذا اللي سويته وما بين جدل في العراق
وقانون اردني تتحدث الاوساط السياسيه هنا
ان حزب البعث الاردني حزب محلي يمارس
نشاطاته داخليا تحت مظله القانون دون اي
تجاوزات او تدخلات خارجيه مرحله حزبيه
جديده في الاردن لم تغادرها احزاب
ديمقراطيه او قوميه ولا يعني ترخيص حزب
البعث الاردني انه منطلق لاستفزاز الجوار
او استدعاء للتاريخ بحسب مراقبين هنا
وانما هي شروط الحياه الحزبيه بالالوان
والاطياف كافه
تحولت هذه القضيه هنا في بغداد الى ماده
اعلاميه وفرصه لشد عصب جمهور بعض الاحزاب
الشيعيه والتي نظمت وقفات احتجاجيه واصدرت
بيانات الادانه لقرار عمان بتجديد رخصه
عمل حزب البعث العربي الاردني
هناك قوى شيعيه ذهبت الى مطالبه حكومه
السودان باتخاذ مواقف اكثر حده تجاه
الحكومه الاردنيه على خلفيه سماحها لبعض
رموز وقيادات حزب البعث العراقي المنحل
بالاقامه على اراضيها وعلى الحكومه
العراقيه لا تكتفي فقط باستدعاء السفير
الاردني يجب ان يكون هناك موقف تجاه هذه
السياسه انا اعتقد ممارسه نشاط حزب البعث
من داخل
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه يشكل خطر ليس
فقط على العراق وانما يشكل خطر على
المنطقه
الشارع العراقي لم يعرف اهتماما لما يجري
فقد بات حزب البعث بالنسبه له جزءا من
الماضي والله هذا الشيء داخل الاردن
والعراق ما اله علاقه باي شيء حزب البعث
في الاردني حزب سياسي اردني ياخذ الاجازه
بالاردني يمارس نشاطة سياسي داخل الاردن
وهذا شيء داخلي اردني
غالبيه القوى والفعاليات السياسيه في
العراق اعتبرت ما جرى في الاردن شان
داخليا لا يؤثر على العلاقه بين بغداد
وعمان والتي تشهد تطورا كبيرا سياسيا
وامنيا واقتصاديا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات